Lady Elizabeth thank you very much
indeed for welcoming to your beautiful
home how long have you been here
forty-three years what can you tell us
about royal parties that you've
organized in the past you know they're
so different to you know what they were
because I think my first royal one was I
started in 1960 probably was 1960
suddenly the Queen Mother was I mean and
life in in the 60s was pretty formal you
know they were pretty sort of set things
so therefore a royal part it wasn't very
different to somebody else's party in
the way that now you know there are so
many sort of gimmicks and olden I mean I
remember it being absolutely amazing
when Prince Angelus 18 or 21 having
lasers nobody seen lasers and but I mean
the thing about a royal party is that
that this first of all space is going to
be very large and it is unnerving I
think it's unnerving for anybody to go
into those those parties not that they
wanted to be honored how much should
people think to start to pay per head
for a wedding I personally feel that it
is not necessary to have grown marks
champagne to have caviar to have all
these things because if you have the
best pasta and the best salad or the
best bangers and the best mash you are
going to make your guests just as happy
as you give them something very
extravagant you are probably going to
make them happier because they're almost
gonna feel it's more homely I mean I've
done great weddings on cottage pie I'm
William William have a cottage pie no he
had caught us about something I did fall
in yeah I remember
yeah IRA gold isn't kept children and
mustered out of gold
sauce boats and then sorry go sauce but
it was quite funny but you know I think
that
the idea of having a party is to help
you and I get into there and relax it's
not to make us feel totally on edge but
we don't quite know what we're doing at
the next time so all of that comes into
my sort of side of it I'm not going to
say to him they can't have love feet but
I would say to them look you bought a
hundred guests here well 200 guests 300
guests and I'm going to tell you now
that only thirty people in this room are
going to realize you've given them such
a fine wine why not wait and have
something that's very drinkable and have
that when you've got some people who
really love wine and then people sort of
say why did you do that because you'd
make so much more money if you're so
fine and I say cuz I'm a Scot what
happens to her majesty rank you and say
come and organize this party for me how
does that go bit like that
does it help and is it our oath all the
final plans always passed by Her Majesty
before or is it down to that she is
amazing about her attention to detail
and amazing I think a lot of people
think she doesn't want to be involved
and she really does love it hearing all
the details and I've never known anybody
in my life and I certainly am NOT like
that myself who actually checks every
place when it's laid as a dining room
table even if it's a dinner for age I
mean she's got an immaculate eye and you
know she checks it there's a fork
missing or something or do you ever
disagree about the detail don't work
like that do not I mean the thing is my
job is not to work on what I think is
right if I think it's horrendous ly
wrong and somebody's gonna you know fall
over sixteen barrels of bags or whatever
I'm an outset or if I think that they're
trying to score five hundred people into
a space it takes two orders I will say
what sort of challenges will Megan be
facing organising or being involved in
this how much involvement will she have
it in well a certain event days when
when I first did royal weddings now
there's already many
which was the first one you did first
when I helped with I think was Princess
Alexandra right now at the guests all
wore long dresses the women and he wore
long dresses and actually wasn't known
as a word then but it sort of thing that
was a bit like a fascinator and it's
called a hat but it was rarely a
fascinating if you look back on it and
they were useless because the weather
had to have a sort of jacket to it all
words have a long coat to it and the
first royal wedding that wasn't long
dresses in England because in abroad
they kept on burning it was the Duke of
Kent's wedding to Katharine Worsley
because it was it your commence service
and and I think it was thought that it
was how many things in the Abbey all
groups and Paul's or something it sort
of seemed to work with long dresses and
after that that part of it became normal
what is not at all normal about the
average royal wedding is that they have
a very big ball about two two nights of
all that say which is all the guests are
going to be involved all the guests are
gonna be in the Abbey on the church and
everything and a lovely dance and what
you do in a day to get over it and then
you have the church service of eleven
o'clock and then ninety nine percent of
the congregation go home and try and
find a sandwich and rest of them go back
any about fifty of them go back to have
have lunch now that all changed when
Prince ed was married safely rease-jones
and Prince ed was a great traveler I
mean he's done abroad lots of weddings
in his sort of seen things like that and
he decided to have a wedding which is
very foreign at four o'clock in white
tie and the women in long dresses and
then afterwards go on to reception
followed by dinner followed by dancing
and there was no question there was no
murmur of a house so that was no relief
until about two days before when a
cousin of mine Romeo and said Queen
societies wear a hat and I said well I
just can't wear a hat
a particular dress and it did look
rather funny come over the people took
them off you know before they had dinner
well what they did say that became a
sort of more like a continental wedding
and then you go and the next wedding is
Prince William now that your involvement
with William sweating quite a lot yeah
because Prince William's wedding I don't
know that it needed have been completely
like this because he was not it's not as
though he was crap you know he wasn't
he's won away from out of this yeah yeah
but I think to begin with he was given
the most terrifying list with all sorts
of dignitaries and people on it and he
said to his grandmother you know I don't
know how to cope with this and she
rather sweetly said tear it up and start
again put your friends down and then see
what and then Prince Charles decided to
ask Europe not only Europe DeSoto's was
he learned you know all sorts of things
well who was going to look after the
night before the wedding me and so I did
that and that's quite fun and then I
looked after though did that involve
being involved at dinner and all those
foreign roles know each other quite well
so they're all quite pleased to see each
other and I included a lot of commoners
to who I need we're going to wait and
say that they had something to talk to
you the next day challenging dietary
requirements it is the most terrifying
thing I mean I will never do it at a
party actually put the work those words
tart requirements if I think if
somebody's got an allergy to something
they really can't eat they're gonna tell
me the easiest thing ever to do is to
try and make the first course vegetarian
because if the first course is
vegetarian you haven't got to worry
about about that because that's that's
quite a high on the list so what did the
day actually involve a Soros wedding was
concerned well today the day involved
the night involved lucky is it I mean
look she said I think I'll go home and
maybe everybody else would say she went
home at about how fast
clock island today sort of seemed to
involve an awful lot of very early
starts and I was in charge of these
foreign the all truth yeah and a lot of
in my relations through marriage the
European ones but I mean I'm not related
to King as well as the land or I think
asoto but I was in charge of them and so
when we came out of the Abbey I just
sort of follow these sort of roads
because roads came at last and I thought
it would be nothing ice if they'd give
me a nice soldier to walk behind me down
the Abbey as opposed to just me it sort
of purple person looking just sort of
goofing up their skirts and I then had
to marshal them all into black buses and
get them up to the rooms and I had to
Kings was its current king of Tonga
rather who was enormous but had taken
off a lot of weight and was on a stick
said to me the night before I'm really
worried when I go tomorrow because I'm
very heavy and I don't want to break any
of her master's chairs so I said don't
worry I will I will I'll guide you to
something and I said the things that
look very squat with tiny legs that
absolutely solid as anything and nobody
to brakeman and he didn't break them
having got them into all these rooms so
the next thing was that they that every
crowned head had to sign the register
but nobody actually told me about this
and then somebody did and I didn't have
anybody to help me I don't know I didn't
have anybody to help me that became
really rather bought so in the end
actually I did find it a very nice
soldier and I got him to hold the book
and I went round and I said would you
mind signing the Queen's visitors book
because it just sort of speeds it up
yeah and we had canapes and it was much
more modern which is Katharine and
William have been to lots of weddings
this is where it started to change
because with the rest of them they
hadn't but they're in the pre
predecessors and there hasn't been to
lots of weddings so you didn't know what
to expect but Katherine and William had
probably been to more weddings than most
people between them say they actually
knew what they wanted
and so as opposed to not having anything
afterwards we all went back to the
palace and we had canapes at lunchtime
and what sort of canapes it's sort of
mostly savory and quite small by them
because Charles and Camilla's weddings
they were quite big and tricky is it
when you've got a glass and then it's
not right oh yes it is
so therefore it's got to be in one bite
and um one of these hugely big Ang's was
around was the biggest suddenly said to
me where's lunch and that was wrong but
there was more food in the evening was
that never then does a break break
because none of these elves and grand
people came in the evening right stopped
off at McDonald's on the way spl1 good
one not dude actually yeah and there was
another one went into an Italian Muslim
and it well it wasn't enough and they
were very good but it wasn't enough and
I tried to get them out of all other
sort of three royal rooms to mix in with
the people I didn't introduce into the
night before and somehow the palace
hadn't got the message and we weren't
really a large I'm so we sort of stuck
because they weren't really used to
doing it that that way and I think the I
mean this is this one and printed
versions are completely different even
to that do you think they'll be sibling
rivalry with this wedding and Harry will
be looking at what William did and think
we're not going to do that oh you're
gonna do it no because I don't think
dinner I think remember that Megan sorry
okay a little bit because I was I've
been calling and Megan and now it's
making a mess right Megan
yeah because Megan is more in charge of
all of that so I think it will be more
Americanized what do you think that form
will say when you say Americanized what
do American wedding I've never been
married actually or somebody is the
rehearsal dinner right you know he's in
America there was ever a saltiness SARS
I know there isn't now I would say that
she was taking care of that sort of
detail and I did rather
maybe wrongly or rightly a bit so to the
chef you have to remember an awful lot
of people who have been in the Army are
going to be at this wedding and they
will think this is lunch you know
because it's it's not really lunch I
mean as far as the meals concerned so
feed them properly it's what you mean
you know what I'm saying put back the
bridge rails that turned up at some
Prince Charles's wedding nobody yet
because it was three bites and feed them
but the thing is I think they're going
to be away from the castle by AAPIs way
and then have a break and then they'll
go don't go to the after-party which
Charles is through I think Charles is
throwing the after party I read that in
what in hello magazine so it must be
right certainly it's right I was in the
fireworks as well yes looking forward to
that it's it's very different isn't it
when you have sort of you know because
we are two nations divided by a common
language and the Americans must be quite
a challenge organizing a wedding or a
party whether it's two different
nationalities but I've done a lot of
American weddings and very often and
I've done lots and lots of foreign
weddings because sometimes people find
it easier to say let's go and get
married in London because then they can
have less people you see I mean though
if they were at home they'd have to us
let's say a hundred people and if they
want to keep it very small they're
clever 20 yeah but they're not twenties
but the difference that we don't have
that they have and I have not a clue
what's happening on this is they have
rehearsal dinners and the rehearsal
dinner the night before is for all the
people who've traveled very far so
anybody upset says come over America or
Australia or New Zealand or France or
whatever they've come into the country
gets invited to the rehearsal dinner and
then there are a whole lot of extremely
embarrassing speeches to the bride and
then the bride has to Nifty off by about
ten and the wedding is the next day I
hear Meghan is actually gonna make a
speech which she feels was late will it
be very interesting but you see none of
us will hear it will we why not cuz it
won't be broadcast no but you're going
to be there alright
Oh probably adjustments
as far as cakes are concerned when I got
married I actually had a chocolate
wedding cake and I think Kate's I think
Megan's having a elderflower cake I read
I mean gee are you a traditionalist when
it comes to cakes no not at all but I am
a practical person and as soon as I
heard that that her old of our cake was
going I thought to myself a plate a fork
a napkin
mm-hmm with the traditional wedding cake
nothing extra so you've got the plate
the fork and the napkin and the
elderflower cake her handbag gloss the
whole thing because I imagine an
elderflower cake is not something to
pick up in her fingers and know and eat
so you're not worried about the washing
up it's more about everything that it's
not no it's more about the birthdays are
they gonna drip bowl the flour cake down
the front of their frocks because they
haven't got anything to put it on yeah
or you know how it's going to be served
mmm I think there's going to be a flute
one as well oh good good um how are you
on these clips that go on the side of
the plate so you can put your clasp on
them
well sure but I watched disasters
because what happens on the whole I mean
it all looks terrific mmm and then you
decide I'd rather fed up this plate and
you put it down and because the glass
hits the thing glass goes up in the end
all the wine goes all the way over the
food and actually there are a complete
disaster I mean they did work if you had
a sort of special glass I think but if
you can imagine nothing oh I think I'll
get rid of this you don't necessarily
think I better take the wine glass out
of it and you go like that and as you
can see what would happen the stem of
the glass goes you're done quite a few
celebrity parties as well haven't you
Mick Jagger mm-hm
and what was the most they'll tell me
about his party what can you tell me
about that first of all I've done credit
quite a few for him but I did one for
all of them the stones down at a very
dilapidated hotel in Maynard where I
knew however much they sort of bashed
and crashed
they couldn't really get us for
redecoration about that before the
decoration in hotels and it was on the
River Thames and I think more Don Payne
your ended up in the Thames then get
drunk and in fact I was asked to get
divers the next day to go down and
retrieve it the bottle you know but I
mean Mick Jagger's a very civilized
terribly nice person I mean with all
these things it's you know how the
guests gonna behave that's a any that's
the only sort of thing in everything I
mean it could happen at Prince Harry's I
mean how do you know how he's guests
together behave at the after party you
don't the Royals are gonna behave well
aren't they I would imagine so what
about me
no it's just that I did one not at all a
wedding but something else and I thought
oh this is fine and they're all remain
perfectly sober and I don't have to
worry about security here and security
there and I've never got it more wrong
never got it more wrong and it was very
much because the world family don't have
very much money so it was very much as
me and my staff during the tearing out
oh the transitive tables and that
generation you know who decided they
weren't going to get given enough to
drink used to bring their half bottles
of rum whiskey gin vodka you might have
empty bottles under the table it was
desperate desperate I thought nothing
they're all gonna behave so well young
people for you Luzi they don't know what
families looks like after the friends
anyway it just seems I mean they don't
know me there they're having badly with
but should we say Harry's too old for
that
no let's say that yeah do you know
anything about the celebrations that you
can tell us about and I can't tell you
anything about that okay I think I'd be
fabulous there we can say that I'm very
very generous in what they've let the
general public know that you don't know
normally no I mean you don't normally
know you're going to have an elderflower
cake hmm or that the florist is going to
be X or
you don't know those sort of things and
so I think they're being very generous
in what they've what one's seen how much
one reads is true I don't know I'm just
wondering how she's going to get up the
steps of the church but I think she'll
probably go in through the side entrance
I remember her Majesty going up the
steps of st. Paul's for a service when
our chicken veteran was in hospital at
the time when he was you only during one
of her and I want to say was probably
the Golden Jubilee it was when you've
got rained on a boat yeah and she walked
up those steps on her own all the way up
to simple's and she did look quite frail
but she you know she managed it so I'm
sure it's rightly wearing five year olds
wearing a two-term wedding dress with no
without the father on the side no no I
mean she was already there at the top of
the steps all right
so but you know she's 35 I'm sure she'll
be skipping up those steps she's about
to marry her prince I hear that they're
gonna hope they're hopeful to have a
baby within a year good for nailing for
them um most extravagant regrets you've
ever received I'm not very good at
extravagance because I actually rather
deplore Eve so probably I'm spending my
time saying I really don't think it's
necessary to have that I did have a very
extravagant request last year though and
actually knee it but I think the
wonderful thing if you can do it with
extravagance is to do something and it
doesn't look as though it's loads of
money if you suddenly do a party where
you do huge bowls tipped like this of
caviar the whole we're under on that is
extravagance and that it to me is vulgar
that's opulence where it goes wrong but
when you can do something possibly with
the same amount of caviar but in a
different presentation so if I I'm very
I'm not I'm particularly not known for
extravagance
I'm much more known for sort of calm
elegance what tips would you offer
people who are going along to their
first royal wedding
don't take a present
because there won't be anywhere to put
it don't be late
creatures is anything else and remember
it's two human beings who are actually
doing something one hopes that they
really want to do which is getting
married and there's nothing really
because all those people
whatever grand titles and things they've
got underneath that whole thing housing
they are human beings with that
something hopelessly in love as well
don't they turn down this absolutely
babe it's actually not gross is it no I
mean it's just a dory and what are your
tips for the bride to enjoy her day
remember when you're planning your
wedding not that this exists in this one
not to have it too late in the day
because from the moment you wake up that
morning
it's a wedding day and if it's at five
o'clock and you wake up at six in the
morning it's a long day this is actually
rather a day of getting up incredibly
early I would imagine she'd have to get
up in order to get ready to go by 11
o'clock so what's your tip for her to
have a great day eat porridge line your
stomach before you start and not too
much booze there probably not before I
don't know I think you have to put
yourself into her it's your own cocoon
really I mean I can't imagine this is
the probably the most media attentive
wedding has ever been in our family what
do you think would be judged as a
success for this royal wedding how would
it be judged as successful and I think
it's I think in general because the
public are so behind this and are
particularly so behind Harry that
whatever it is it's going to be a
success if you can understand what I'm
saying I think that it's actually now
what I am and I even said it to them I
mean I sort of when they got engaged in
those photographs in that interview it
actually made your heart really feel
warm towards them and I said you know
that so loved it you can give all the
rest of us
such pleasure from your own happiness
and I think that's key and no nobody
ever has been so tactile before so you
wouldn't really have known whether what
they felt about each other that this was
sort of completely natural and very
tactile we certainly know what love is
with those two you do and yet it hasn't
been embarrassing it hasn't Elizabeth
it's a pleasure thanks so much thanks
for your time